[Aplausos]
boa noite pessoal eu queria propor um
pequeno teste pra gente
agora passou grande parte do nosso dia
nós viemos estavam de ensolarado agora à
noite começa a chegar
eu queria falar exatamente dessa
dinâmica que acontece no nosso olhar e
falar de escuridão e falar de luz
pense no que acontece com nossos olhos
quando a gente deixa o ambiente escuro e
vai até um ambiente claro os olhos dói a
gente demora a se acostumar se habituar
a essa nova visão e assim eu digo a
vocês e quero compartilhar com vocês a
idéia de fagulhas a superação a uma
fagulha ela tem que ser nós nascemos na
era do computador e achamos que tudo é
assim não é
acontece um problema o que que a gente
quer fazer
resolvi resolver a vida não vai fazer
assim conosco
a vida vai jogar uma baita escuridão e
desculpem pela minha empolgação mas a
gente tende a combater os obstáculos e
não se adaptar a eles
dá pra que essa lâmpada surgisse foi
necessário uma tremenda preparação uma
tremenda aceitação de uma série de
limites
eu quero queira quer não sou portador de
uma lesão cerebral significa dizer que
três pontos do tamanho de cabeça de
alfinete estão inutilizáveis no meu
cérebro e portanto foi necessário um
processo de formiguinha para que se
acendessem novos caminhos que não
aqueles que tiraram toda luz todo o
brilho dos olhos dos meus pais diziam
marcos
será cego será surdo deixem no fundo de
uma cama porque a lesão tende a se
espalhar
o menino tem de aparecer foi totalmente
uma perda de luminosidade foi totalmente
um ambiente escuro para os quais o qual
meus pais não estavam preparados e aí
começaram a acender suas próprias luzes
através de oito horas diárias de
exercícios padronização e reorganização
neurológica
o meu cérebro começou a associar e
assimilar os padrões normais de
aprendizagem e aí comecei a perceber os
caminhos que a via no horizonte
mais tarde aos sete anos quando tudo
estava iluminado quando todos os
contornos não pareciam mais tão
desafiadores veio outro problema outra
escuridão incerteza o ser humano né tem
medo do desconhecido
quem aqui não tem medo do que não
conhece acender uma luz é conhecer as
potencialidades de fábio linha em
paulinha nós superamos aos sete anos
como dizia a minha família é necessária
foi autismo
ninguém sabia o que era pouco se falava
sobre isso quem deu a dica foi uma
professora estudando psicopedagogia e
especialização mas nós fomos atrás fomos
ascendendo essa centelha de razão ante a
um cenário pouco razoável
pesquisamos lemos cada um pouco e o meu
pai minha mãe e do meu irmão os colegas
os vizinhos começaram aos poucos a ser
contagiados e a entender que o autismo
tem suas limitações
eu comecei a perceber que há vários
exemplos de que a razão seja nossa
principal aliada para acender essa luz
esse é o lícias ou desceu um herói que
ante a todos os desafios usou do
intelecto em detrimento da força às
vezes a gente sabe precisamos dos dois
mas esse enfrentou sua odisséia com a
cabeça e foi isso que meus pais fizeram
também e hoje eu faço aproveitou dessa
centelha de superação para compartilhar
com o mundo
que diferença eu posso fazer quantos
lugares escuros eu posso iluminar com as
minhas ideias
comecei na internet
comecei cantando percebi que fazia muito
sucesso não de mensuração de público não
de não as de transformação de alguma
realidade quente
a música tem um compasso a vida não tem
compasso quando se aprende as formas de
compassos e aprendi então se pode dar
sentido à vida o sentido que a gente
quer pelo menos 345 minutos depende da
duração da canção e isso eu percebia
muitas evolutivas de pessoas que diziam
puxa você canta em inglês você canta em
alemão
você canta em espanhol e gente eu nunca
fui à espanha
nunca fui a inglaterra nunca fui à
alemanha mas a música me fez viajar e
olha só
nem paguei os 2.000 dois mil e
quinhentos reais de uma passagem de
volta para a europa e aprende
aprendi então que a realidade pode ser
feita com a razão deste cara do mero do
homero não do mercoul melo é o autor
desse cara do lis e ainda que a coisa
seja o mérica aí sim encontrei a palavra
nós centelha anos com a razão sempre e
mais pessoas fizeram isso ao longo da
história quantas vezes esse cara foi
desacreditado voava de dirigíveis super
difíceis de controlar
explodiram alguns eram vôo pouco
tradicional e aí
anos depois ele veio com o 14 bis de
santos dumont um herói da razão
um herói da iluminação de cenários
difíceis e assim como santos dumont para
nós
sonho de voar gente sejamos brasileiros
não foi os irmãos wright está o santos
dumont por favor que é brasil vamos
fazer com que essa identificação chega
né pelo menos 14 bis era mais bonitinho
que o flyer dos light né
enfim ele usou a razão o lixo sou a
razão eu estou usando a razão e aí
quando contava pra vocês do youtube do
poder da música eu quanto a vocês agora
que aprendi que falar de autismo também
é assim
se eu pude aprender alemão inglês
espanhol sem nem mesmo ter ido a esses
países eu poderia informar quebrando
toda aquela cientificidade acerca do
autismo
o transtorno do espectro autista e aí eu
ri chorei
compartilhei com uma câmera assim é
pequena e um grande sonho de que o
autismo deixasse de ser algo
especulativo e pra cada especulação eu
tinha uma idéia para cada especulação eu
acendia a luz e elucidava os contornos
escuros que a desinformação que o
desconhecimento proporcionava e eu me
adaptava à obstáculo sem ter que tirar
da minha frente propriamente dita
isso eu quero deixar também pra vocês
quando acontecer alguma coisa incerta
tentei entender o obstáculo e do que se
trata e pra cada ponto tortuoso na nossa
trajetória seja aqui no tb becks seja ao
longo da vida uma centelha de iluminação
com a ideia que queremos passar essa
idéia ela transforma o nosso mundo
interior e transformando o mundo
interior
ela nos faz estar a analisar essa
questão também é muito importante eu
quase esqueci dela
o youtube e à sua proveniência de
serviços de streaming ela ele faz com
que a gente internalize sinalizar para
uma pessoa autista não é tão fácil assim
né onde muitos autistas
eu faço palestras
respeito as pessoas vêm perguntar mas é
muito otimistas têm dificuldade de
externalizar é como é que faz
é um pouquinho a cada vez e eu acredito
que os vídeos tenham medo dado o
potencial pra explicar esses pouquinhos
para as famílias que a minha maior
alegria hoje é ver que o autista não é
um recluso
essa é apenas uma competição de
estímulos que o autista prefere não
participar mas que ele pode participar
com outras de evolutivas ao mundo que
essa luz pode ser de várias idéias de
várias intenções e intensidades
diferentes e que com isso nós podemos
transformar a nossa realidade e pensar
na questão global eu penso na questão
global do autismo como é que esses
artistas que estão sendo diagnosticados
hoje vamos ser no futuro como é que vão
vivenciar os estímulos e como é que vão
participar ativamente da sociedade
mas vocês podem pensar em várias das
suas idéias cada um no seu cada um cada
um aí refletindo como pode como está a
seu alcance
só não deixem que os olhos que se fecham
perante a mudança de luz
façam com que a gente fique paralisado o
medo assusta o desconhecido aliás
assusta mas o importante é que ele não
paralise
eu por vezes fui tentado a ficar
paralisado
ante a dificuldade de entender algumas
emoções humanas este é um estágio
constante dos autistas temple grandin
grande exponent do autismo e proponente
do tratamento racional dos animais nos
estados unidos que revolucionou o
mercado da carne se comparava uma vaca
mas aí você se pergunta por que vaca
porque ela tinha medo constante
o medo constante das agruras e dos
contornos imprecisos que a vida assume
um autista estar aqui pra esse autista
aliás estar aqui
dez anos atrás não seria possível luz
demais som demais principalmente som
demais
eu treinei isso através da música está
em análise em muita coisa e hoje eu
endossa a idéia de que um pouco a cada
vez
nós podemos iluminar o nosso caminho e
fazer da nossa trajetória produtiva e
participativa no meio onde a gente está
e transformar isto através da
diferenciação ou da apropriação são duas
posturas que se estuda na faculdade né
que muitos de vocês
enquanto os administradores existem aqui
eu me pergunto não precisa levantar a
mão só faça essa reflexão quando se você
já não ouviram essa estratégia do ao né
você pode se aproximar ou você pode se
afastar
assim a nossa centelha nós podemos
permanecer no mesmo ângulo de iluminação
como eu poderia pegar essa lâmpada agora
e iluminar a passagem a paisagem de um
modo diferente
falando em expressar eu consegui um
grande amigo chamá lo pra contar a
história para vocês de como eu pude
entender a fronteira final que é o amor
eu conciliei o amor por uma pessoa com
amor por uma idéia que iluminou os
caminhos e silenciou um pouco dos
rumores também tornou as agruras mais
fáceis de se entender essa composição é
minha chama se a garota que sabe voar
vou tocar um pouco pra vocês
[Música]
[Aplausos]
ae
[Música]
nem temos a mesma nunca está só
sua força toca bem melhor
a amiga alice no a lutar é a garota sabe
[Música]
ela sonha para que está é a garota sabe
do quarto ela sirva para conquistá la
sabiá e se algum dia tiver pedida a
saída vai encontrar isto aprendeu na
vida é gaveta que sabe boba
[Música]
[Aplausos]
valeu pessoal mas mais importante do que
endossar uma ideia personificando a como
eu fiz nessa canção eu sempre quis
entender as questões do amor eu disse
que era a última fronteira pra vocês não
foi por acaso porque se expressar é uma
questão muito escura não estamos falando
de iluminar caminhos aqui
o amor é sempre uma nova descoberta e
com o diário de um autista
talvez não consiga discutir a magnitude
que ele tem
apesar de já ter falado sobre isso mas
cantar me aproxima um pouco mais do amor
outro amor que eu tenho enquanto não
encontra o amor afetivo quanto ainda não
entendo com uma determinada acurácia é o
amor pelas letras o escritor britânico
neil gaiman num dado trecho do livro a
fifa blue chips ites à vista dos
assentos barato sem tradução em
português disse o seguinte a escrita
conta mentiras mas estas mentiras contra
us de como o mundo poderia ser e no meu
mundo poderia ser expressado diferente
adaptado diferente para que eu
entendesse de uma forma diferente os
obstáculos pelas quais estou passando
pelos quais um escritor que cometeu um
pequeno erro aqui vocês vêm do orçamento
sabe que a obra se algum dia encontrar
em mas enfim a escrita explicar vá assim
como a música explicou
e entende o mundo muito mais
é da maneira com que se apresenta porque
para um autista dificuldade que faz esse
cenário escuro que eu propus no começo
grande parte dela vem do fato do autista
ser literal ou seja dizem pra mim marcos
aquela mulher é uma gata e eu imaginava
gatos
essa situação está russa mas como a
situação tá russo se ela está
acontecendo no brasil não é uma situação
brasileira então são metáforas que guiam
nossa vida que moldam nossos sonhos e
que eu entendi através de escrita
escrevendo também me expressei muito
melhor então eu digo a vocês também
quando iluminar em um cenário indefinido
com uma ideia forte que vocês tiverem
que de brilho nos olhos e que mova vocês
na direção de um sonho expressem na
porque é uma postura acessível não só
pela escrita nós vimos tantos exemplos
de ideia hoje compartilhando aqui dentro
e fora desse evento ao longo da na
produção desse evento né
nós podemos precisar de formas
diferentes expressando nós podemos levar
os nossos sonhos nosso brilho nos olhos
e no coração também se não tiver coração
não tem razão nem os dois dançam numa
dança meio louca de se entender mas é
verdade coração está conectada razão a
gente pega as pessoas pelo coração né
e aí vocês nós precisamos expressar da
maneira com que esse processo para que
isso não morra
o meu sonho de evidenciar o autismo e de
escrever profissionalmente não morreu
porque eu tenho grandes outros sonhos
que eu expresso através deles e hoje
estou sendo chamado nas escolas por
exemplo pra expressar melhor a vida de
pessoas autistas e receber a devolutiva
dos pais iluminando cada vez mais o
caminho dos nossos sonhos
muito obrigado pela atenção de vocês
[Aplausos]